thank you for showing up we will get
right under way the first talk of the
day is first talk of the afternoon has
done this evening thank you Eric thanks
for coming I'd like to start by thanking
the organizers for inviting me it's
great to be here this wonderful meeting
so in this talk I want to present a
joint work with them you on top from
Paris and informally the results has the
following for a large class of interest
in computational problems two things can
happen it's sort of an algorithmic
dichotomy result either a very simple
algorithm a linear program relaxation
solves every instance in this class or
the other case very powerful as deep
relaxation doesn't solve this class of
problems so how do we formalize large
class of interesting computation
problems well this is what liberal did
for us so the framework of constraint
satisfaction problems and I hope you all
went to the talk in the morning is a
allows you to talk about lots of
problems rather than individual problems
and when I say cspc a constraint
satisfaction problems I mean most the
decision problems you should think of
problems like to sorry sir three line
equations over with three or three
coloring and there's an impressive body
of literature on decision CSPs a lot of
great people some of them are here and a
lot of breakthroughs in recent in recent
years and in an almost disjoint universe
with some overlap are very small one
this possibly even bigger body of
literature larger body of literature a
result of work on Mac CSPs when you try
to maximize the number of satisfied
constraints perhaps approximately and
you should think of problems such as max
got maxed you in mastic SAT and so on
and again has been huge progress in this
area in last few years lots of
breakthroughs I'll mention some in this
talk I want to talk about a more general
class of CSPs which includes these two a
special cases so it allows you to mix
both the sort of decision csps
homomorphism problems if you like and
maxius peace purely optimization problem
it allows you to talk about things like
vertex cover which is not a decision CSP
if you talk about non-uniform CSPs with
a fixed template it allows you to
include things like locally defined sub
module
functions and and other stuff so let me
give you three examples of problems you
all know in this framework especially
the first one will look strange so this
is a free coloring and the way I want to
see it is even though it's a decision
problem i want to see it as an
optimization problem sort of when I so I
have a it's a minimization problem where
I minimize over all possible assignments
of the three available colors to the
vertices of the graph and the objective
function is given as the sum of binary
terms and each term comes from an edge
in the graph and the function sitting
there is in fact the relation but i want
to see there's a function which returns
zero or infinity and the obvious thing
so if the two arguments are the same its
infinity 0 otherwise so minimizing this
function really asks about is it
possible to get a proper coloring is
that is the smallest value for this
expression 0 or is it infinity this is a
pure decision problem the second example
is a max cut in these guys in the
minimization version minimum uncut we
try to minimize the number of edges in
red so within the two partitions and
this talk I want to see this problem is
a minimization problem where you
minimize / assigning 0 and once to the
vertices of the graph so there are 1
correspond to the two partitions of the
graph and the objective function you
minimize is a again some of binary terms
and each term comes from an edge and
this time the function looks like this
if the two arguments are the same it
returns one they are definitely an 0
every Simon that corresponds to
partition gives you the size of the
compartment of the cut you try to
minimize this
and the third and final example is the
vertex cover problem and here I'll view
this again minimization problem you
minimize over assignments of zero and
once to the vertices of the graph one
meaning in the cart 0 meaning out of the
car and the objective function slightly
more complicated this time so the first
some comes with unary terms for each
vertex in the graph and essentially it
counts the number of vertices assigned
one so it's the size of the cover and
the second some make sure that the
vertices be selected by signing the one
is indeed a cut so the function makes
you that so this function psi is comes
from the edges of the graph and it's not
possible to assign both endpoint zeros
would correspond to energy that is not
covered ok so these are the examples
purely decision p optimization and sort
of mix of the two mixing both sort of
just rational values and these
infinities it's forbidden valleys so
these are just three examples of this a
general framework which is called valued
or generally csps is a generalization of
CSP and max ESP or min CSP to be precise
and the definition definition is as
follows so useful and communication is
to denote by Q Bar the set of rationals
extended with positive infinity and V
cspo value TSP instance is given by and
variables x1 through xn the finite
domain D and an objective function I
have x1 to xn and the objective function
is given as the sum of terms each term
is a fixed already function so it's
given explicitly by all possible
assignment so if the early skates mode
of D to the K values and the goal is to
find an assignment of labels from D to D
variables that minimizes I exactly
there's an exact optimization problem
now if you vary the codomain of the
functions defies you get as i said
before CSP as a special case min or max
ESP it doesn't matter because we do
things exactly it was approximately this
this wouldn't be true but it will
consider the case when it's q bar to bar
so on
the most general version
and one more piece of notation so VCS p
of gamma is the class of all VCS p
instances of the form of this form where
all the files in the objective function
come from fixed set of functions gamma
so gamma is called the constraint
language or template this is the most
studies class of CSP and VCS peace when
you fix the set of allowed constraints
or functions in your instance
we see them or describing certain
language so in this talk will assume
that gamma is finite on a fixed finite
of my deed so can be given explicitly
sometimes people consider infinity 0
cameras as well okay so the main result
now you know at least two things by the
large class of interesting commutation
problems I mean these general of ETS
piece parameterize by language and by
solving it I mean minimizing this
objective function exactly what do I
mean by a simple linear program
relaxation so every VC SB instance has a
very natural in EM program relaxation
which is called a basic or canonical p
relaxation and sometimes it works and
sometimes it doesn't meaning it's it's
it has a fractional solutions and
there's a systematic way of making the
relaxation stronger and stronger is this
hierarchy of shell era sure the atoms
which has a parameter l and it it the
bigger the better if l equals to end
then actually the the relaxation is
tight so let me tell you the definition
so this is the VCS be instance we make
sure that every subset of at most l
variables where l is the parameter of
the shell items relaxation a pace in the
scope of some function some fire if it
doesn't we can always throw it in and
put there some say constants your
function it doesn't change the objective
function at all
now the variables of the relaxation alum
does with two parameters I gives you the
number of the term in the objective
functions from 1 to Q and Sigma is an
assignment of labels to the variables in
the ith term in the objective function
and it's a variable which is between 0
and 1 and you should think of it as a
probability probability that the aight
term in the objective function the
variables in the ICM get assigned values
according to Sigma sort of local
assignments and now the relaxation says
the following so the constraints are all
lambdas should be non-negative well if
you want them to be probabilities for
the local assignment Sigma's we try to
an infinity we want those lambdas to be
0 we don't want allow these infinite
values so that's what it means hear
something the domain of the fine if you
look at the ith term in the objective
function and you some the properties
over all possible assignments to the 8th
them they should sum up to 1 as
probabilities should and the most
interesting part is the last set of
constraints so this is a marginalization
if I look at two terms say the aight 1 +
jate one and the set of variables of the
Jade one is a subset of the set of rob
us of the 81 I want to marginalization
so the probability let's say the Jade
term gets assigned tau is equal to the
probabilities of the assignments these
are some of the properties of the
assignments that extent tau to the to
the bigger scope I and here's the
parameter L so we this is done only if
the smaller scope is of size at most
I'll now if these variables were 01
valued rather than between 0 and 1 the
objective function of the LP relaxation
would be the same as of the VCS be
instance but because it's not it can be
generally between 01 it's not quite as
I'm an issue think of this is the
expectation the expected value of the
objective function with respect to this
property distributions Islam does now if
L is fixed this is a polynomial size
relaxation you can solve it
so the simple LP relaxation is a result
corresponds to the third level of the
chalet gnomes
now what do I mean the powerful as deep
relaxation so this is a lesser
relaxation so lassie relaxation of semi
different programs is a strengthening of
the shower I'm sure our key where you
replace the lambdas which previously
were just numbers between 0 and 1 by
vectors from some farmer finite
dimensional vector space see from our to
the T and you also have a one more extra
variable which lambda sub zero so they
are now involved because they should be
vectors
and the relaxation isn't I mean a lot of
Ekron ways of doing it but this is the
one from the literature so it doesn't
correspond precisely to the previews
money you could make them almost
syntactically identical so let's have a
look so we want this lambda 0 to be unit
vector you should you should think of
these lambdas so that if you take the
norm of its squared as the probability
saw this content you should think of
what is the probability that the ith
term gets assigned values according to
according to Sigma as before so for
instance if the local assignment gets a
infinite value then it's zero if you
take in a product of any two it's
non-negative some should be unit vector
if you look at any two assignments an
assignment to the ice term sigma sub I
and assignment to the gesture sigma sub
J if they have some variables in common
and they assign different values they
are sort of inconsistent so you want
this product to be zero this corresponds
to the marginalization in a way so this
says that if you take four scopes IJ RS
and if the union of the variables in the
Jade and Jade scope is the same as the
union of the variables in the earth and
ESCO and if you take assignments to
these scopes which are consistent
meaning on the variables that have in
common get assigned the same values then
the inner product on the right hand side
should be equal to the inner product on
the right hand side
the last set of constraints says that if
you look at scopes of size one so
schools of size one sort of correspond
to variables the original VCS be instant
and if you look at all the possible
assignments which in this case I didn't
didn't denote them by Sigma but by a
indie because it's just a single label
so some of the sort of probabilities is
equal to one this is a very strong
relaxation again if L is fixed and this
is the polynomial size location which
can be solved up to an small additive
error up to an arbitrary small arbitrary
additive error exactly and if the l is
equal to n the number of variables
similar to the shall items hierarchy you
actually have a tight polytope so it
precisely corresponds to the convex
combinations of the solutions to the
original instance the trouble is that
the in the realization is not of polymer
size so it's not clear how to solve it
right even if you want to say take a
look at the you'll it's still not quite
clear so the intuition behind these
lambdas so the intuition is that rather
than using show them that we have just
properties these times their vectors so
the the squares of the norms are still
you think of them as probabilities but
now they don't come from arbitrary
numbers but they have to come from inner
products of vectors so it means you
restrict the types of properties you get
much whether it helps or not
paden like amplitudes in quantum
mechanics oh I don't know anything about
quantum but maybe you can tell me
something about quantum off to the top
although their arts complex no sorry did
I say complex anybody that so that was
confusing with the area well there they
come from our to the teeth from some
fixed e okay complex example is positive
semi definite yes okay more questions
clarifications okay
so the second part of the theorem says
that even if you look at so if the if
the level of luster you look at is n it
solves the problem exactly but there is
some constant such that the SE C C times
and level of the lesser hierarchy
doesn't so be doesn't solve the problems
what makes a relaxation stronger than
another you call it a strong relaxation
hear you say a powerful right ok ok so
so these say the khaid level of lhasa
hierarchy is known to be tighter than
the khaid level of the shell items are
working meaning as the politics tighter
so it's a few of fractional solutions ok
so this this lot hierarchy of la sera
actually now in the last few years
people realize that it's the same as the
sum of squares algorithm so this is the
most popular name these days so as nice
connections to proof complex today sum
of squares albert knows a lot about
these but unfortunately is not around ok
so for instance in the era of
approximation these relaxations are the
basis of the most powerful algorithms
people use ride with the commands
williamson breakthrough from the 90s for
mac scott was the album was pretty much
the first level of the LA siroque E and
then Aurora and others had this
approximation algorithm for sparse is
cut so that was the third level of the
LA sir are a pretty much so
okay and there is also some connection
between ceramic atoms and the number of
variables employees under my name I am
there is some and I think I know Janu is
a lot about these things so maybe you
can answer the question Elijah yeah okay
so so I want to make this this dear M
precise and in order to do it I need
polymorphisms but you know everything
about polymorphisms now because of a
liberal stock so you know that
polymorphisms are close your operations
on feasible solutions they much as the
intuition so formally they've or talk
about relations this is a function but
if you have a function you look at the
set of feasible tapos I mean those that
don't return infinite values so in the
case of relation will be just the
topless in the relation and if you take
any of its an MRA operation is a
polymorphism of Phi if you take n am
feasible sort of solutions or tuples
that are in the domain of Phi and you
apply F component wise you get another
feasible solution so the examples to
have in mind is projection sometimes
called dictators charge of Allah
polymorphisms of all functions because
they written one of the arguments and so
people mentioned in the morning an
example of a max binary mac separation
which explains why horns are
destructible here's a different example
majority is a ternary operation on 0 1
which explains why to set is a tractable
really the reason why to start is solve
in polymer time is because actually it
has admits majority as a polymorphism
the algebraic point of view so these are
polymorphisms polymorphisms captured
decision CSP if you want to talk about
channel valued CSPs which include CSP is
a special case but also include other
problems you need to generalize it and
you go to fractional weighted
polymorphisms and these are probability
distributions on on polymorphisms with
some desirable properties so here's the
definition I have a function again 5 I
look at say on it's on the set of em are
a polymorphisms of Phi and a probability
distribution on this set is a fractional
polymorphism if we satisfy this
inequality for all possible X 12 exams
so you should think of these
x 12 x mi sort of feasible solutions to
phi you look at the average value of
these m so that's the right hand side
and the left hand side is the expected
value with respect to the product
distribution that is the attraction
polymorphism how do i call it there
amigo so i give you one example which
probably most of you know it's a very
important example this is the example of
submodular functions so you could define
submodular functions I mean the usual
definition has intersections and unions
and so on but if you know submodular
functions then actually you can define
the class of submodular functions as the
set of functions that admit this
particular probability distribution as
the fractional polymorphism so the
probability distribution on the set of
binary operations that gets probability
half two men and a half to max and zero
to everything else yes I usually it
looks like maybe you could take a
probability distribution over Dom five
instead of just taking exactly am
probably distribution over don't Phi
then add them up on the right-hand side
of the boat could you do that well no
because he you take just I'm over them
right yeah this could be this could be
more than am right Oh what do you mean
yeah let me just take some distribution
over the elements of Tom Phi and then
can you generalize this somehow mommy oh
I have to beat it i see i miss the arity
of ok ok we can talk about
more questions I mean unfortunately this
is slightly technical but if you know
somewhat your functions hopeful this
example helps if you don't submerge your
functions then well you should think on
the most probable distributions /
polymorphisms not arbitrable
distributions but some that I have some
satisfy some linear inequalities okay
now a bounded with condition which
you've heard about actual in the morning
so if you have a set of operation see on
domain D then we say that this set
satisfies the boundary with condition BW
see if for every m at least three
there's a ternary this emery operation
in the set that satisfy this week and
you property so if all the arguments
bond 1r the same then the answer stays
the same this is an example of an ID and
then identity well for the people who
know these things examples of seeds that
satisfy the boundary with condition is
if you take say the binary operation men
we saw before Max and you generate the
clone functional clone from in let me
take majority and you generate the
functional call from this operation okay
so this is the boundary condition and
now I can finally make it the the
statement more precise even if you
didn't get the definition so another
piece of notation the support of gamma
is the set of operations that get
positive probability in some fraction
polymorphism of gamma so in the case of
submodular functions min and Max would
be in the support but others as well
other operations as well so now what
does the theorem say it says that if
gamma is an arbitrary finite set of
functions on some fixed finite sadi then
either the support of gamma satisfies
the boundary with condition in which
case any instance of VCs p over gamma
can be solved exactly by the third level
of the Shalom's hierarchy or the support
of gamma does not satisfy the BBC in
which case this class contains problems
that cannot be solved even by linearly
many levels of the Lasser SDP relaxation
now go at make a dichotomy theorem
and actually by breakthrough a result of
these guys lyraka and register this was
a best paper what it stuck last year the
second one actually implies that no
polynomial size semi definite
programming relaxation of this class of
problems can solve it exactly so which
is astounding I mean this result okay so
where does this condition come from so
in a very important series of papers and
we have some of the authors here it was
established that this condition
precisely captures the power of local
consistency methods for decision csps so
this is known as the bounded with
theorem due to Barton kashagan and
independently obtained by Andre lot of
and later on actually labore and marcin
used the techniques from the result to
show that this condition also captures
all Mac csps that can be robustly
approximated so these guys Victor Darwin
raker can go the sort of the hardest
part if you like and they did the
algorithmic part so now the dis result i
just mentioned you can see how natural
and robust this condition is not only
captures these two it also captures a
the sole ability of general value GSP's
by sdp relaxations of polymer science
I just say a few words about how you
would want to prove such a thing so for
the attractive lady part I mean the
things I like about this part of the
result is a very simple algorithm when
it was announced this is from last year
this actually only this first part it
covered known truck cases that were
known to be tractable I'm much more
complicated algorithms and there were
some new cases such as measuring the
support which surprisingly wasn't known
to be tractable before and the proof
heavily relies on the boundary theorem
it's akeem again so what we do we show
that if the third level of the LP
relaxation has a solution that actually
can find a solution that is closed under
all the operations that are in the
support and once you have that you can
go to decision csps I used bonded with
erm and then use LP jollity to go back
and show that actually the relaxation is
tied the second part of the CRM actually
in this case something much stronger is
known in the approximation community so
if you have a language gamma which
corresponds to equations linear
equations then you not only know that
the linear level of the last sorry
doesn't solve them but doesn't even
approximate them well and this is this a
great result so it was done for the
boolean in the boolean case by shoshana
back in two thousand eight it was
actually rediscovery of old result from
the proof complexity by grigoriev then
to see on a did it four equations over
an abelian group of prime power and
finally Chan was a student he actually
in Berkeley did it for all abelian
groups so this is the starting point
someone's done this for ants and then
again we use the boundary with theorem
which gives us that if if la supportive
gamma doesn't satisfy the bond of its
condition you could get you can get your
hands on equations so the work is to
show that getting to the equations
doesn't change the non solve ability of
the Lasser a linear relaxation so there
are these algebraic instructions liberal
talk over in the morning I go into the
core PP interpretations PP definitions
express about that's what we do and all
these reductions were known to preserve
computational complexity so what we do
we show that they preserve non
solubility of the
so okay
so this is my last slide i believe so i
would like to compare with some known
results in the approximation community
so on the one hand we get a weaker
result in the approximation guys because
we only deal with exact solvability on
the other hand we get a stronger result
in particular this is a characterization
when you know convex relaxations work
exactly and furthermore we do it in the
framework of general value tsps which is
as general as you can get so in the
approximation community people no lots
of stuff about inapproximability of
maxius piece so they 01 valued functions
and then they can often say things about
other problems like say vertex cover by
problem specific reductions so they take
max ESP as a as a start point starting
point and they do a reduction to some
concrete problems they have no tools how
to actually prove it for say all general
valued CSP is where you can mix they
call it strict constraints like in the
vertex cover you want to say you know
both endpoints have to be taken
I think that's it yeah okay I'm done
thank you for attention are there any
more questions maybe you said it in the
first few minutes levels in your story
how does this relate with soft csps and
what do you mean myself chess piece so
stop CSP is you have constraints which I
interpreted as functions from
assignments variables to AC simmering to
symmetry so this is the simmering where
you have a where you have a December
Angus q bar so it's the rationals
together with positive infinity CS piece
might be more general problem much more
general but I don't think the other
simmering czar that interesting but uh
yeah they're sometimes might be
interesting but magnet from the
optimization point yeah yeah so this is
for one particular concrete stammering
that the min plus yeah okay okay is it
down to your question yeah yeah thank
you more questions
right before and after somebody else
either those now okay so can you can go
to the previous slide it's a sham back
for ZB than four powers and a billion
groups it is necessary to you don't have
any kind of reduction to course to
something good then yeah yeah yeah I
think it could be done but it's easy
just to take their result and yeah yeah
yeah yeah that one yes any other
questions